justin you said earlier that you'd been
writing all your life whether it was
novels or scripts so how many scripts
have you written before you actually got
to killing winston jones killing winston
jones was my first feature length script
so um yeah as i mentioned i had written
a lot of shorts i actually wrote a lot
of shorts in college a lot of which um i
produced as well
that we shot and made and some went to
film festivals and some just went to our
living room for our friends to watch um
but kellie wilson jones was the very
first
uh feature that i wrote um
i think i was in a unique situation just
because i had worked so long in a lit
department you know at innovative
artists and had those experiences and
read so many scripts
and done so much coverage that it really
helped me so i wasn't diving in blindly
it
it was the first feature technically but
it wasn't because i'd read so many i
felt like i'd written them in the past
and written them before
so um
but uh yeah technically that that was
the first the very first idea that i'd
come up with that a concept that i'd
seen all the way through to fruition
would you recommend that to other people
coming to la that want to get into the
industry in some sense would they work
there or do you think that would sour
them too much
um on the other end i definitely came
out a different person than when i went
in
i think the word jaded is probably a
little too strong but i think you get a
very strong idea and understanding of
what this industry is all about and like
i said there are a lot of positive
things about this industry
but
it's not as glamorous as some might hope
so
i would highly recommend working either
at an agency a management company or a
production company if screenwriting is
what you want to do work in a lit
department or work as a development exec
or an assistant to a development exact
at a studio or a production company
or potentially be a writer's assistant
any of those jobs that'll help teach you
the business not only the creative side
of it but also the business side of it
primarily is going to help you
so i would highly recommend it i think
the people that come in
and go straight to a job that's just
going to help them financially whether
that's
waiting tables or being a bartender or
whatever it is that they have to do
i think that they
are at a disadvantage i think you have
to be within the industry and seeing the
inner workings of it and if you're not
going to be at least be reading the
trades on a daily basis and know what
the business is all about read as many
books as you possibly can on it
constantly be studying and researching
because that's what's going to help you
be a step above the others if you're
creative and you're a great storyteller
that's one piece of an enormous puzzle
so you have to figure out what all those
other pieces are and i think for me that
started working at caa and innovative
artist and because not only the
experiences it's the connections that
you make and and i've utilized those
connections since the day that i receive
them and and i'm working with people
that i met at innovative still you know
and i'm working with people that i met
at creative artists agency and in
different capacities and scripts and
projects that i'm working on so i think
it's
incredibly important
to to do that route if you can
so when you came out
after working at those two different
places
what was the biggest takeaway just how
much of a business that actually is and
how little it is on the creative
well like i said i don't i don't know
that it's big business and no creative i
think it's a bit of both
um
but you know what i took away is um
just that this
the industry is a very small it's a
tight-knit family it's a group of people
so most of the time 99 of us are on the
outside looking in you know we're trying
to open that window and sneak in or open
the door or knock or ring the doorbell
and it's very difficult to do but
once you can understand what the game is
and what everyone's doing inside of that
house it's a little bit easier to get in
there so you learn so much about
the industry if you're at an agency you
learn so much about production if you're
working in production you know you learn
so much about developing projects
if you're working creatively in a studio
or if you're working in a production
company so i think
work in the industry that you want to be
in and then hopefully one day that comes
to fruition and you can work there
full-time you know it's tricky for a
writer because
a lot of times a writer will
write a script
they'll option it and then you'll be
done
you're lucky if they offer you know you
to be the writer that develops it with
them and does revisions on that script
because ultimately most of the time
they'll bring in other writers or people
that they've worked with in the past
so
writers are sort of on the outside
anyways so any sort of leg up that leg
up is going to be having worked in a
capacity of an agency production company
a studio that's going to help you leaps
and bounds because
you might be leaving to be a writer but
a lot of the people that you worked with
in that capacity aren't leaving and they
are the future of creative execs or they
are the future of producers or the
future agents
and
knowing them and having those
relationships that you developed
especially having gone through
what it takes in the beginning when you
are at the very bottom rung of the
ladder puts you in a family together and
you can utilize those resources so i
think that those are incredibly
important to have and i still use those
today you know i i am so close with
people that i was dragged through the
mud with you know um as lowly assistants
at an agency
and we have stories that we could that
we will constantly tell for the rest of
our lives about you know the different
uh things that happen
um in those agencies in in in that
capacity so um it's it's priceless to
work within the industry um if you can
and
afford to do it and pursue your goals on
the outside you know a lot of people
have to
uh work you know nine to five or nine to
seven and then come home and if they're
a writer write at night and if you're
passionate about it enough or you
believe in your project that's just what
you have to do until you get something
that's uh gets you some traction and and
hopefully gets made for you
and interning is also a good idea so
suppose there's not the job that you
want i think interning is is a good idea
i i didn't intern but i think that if
you can go to
a workspace and convince the people that
you're an asset to their company then
you shouldn't be interning for long the
people who are interning and interning
for quite a long time um may not have
the uh
the qualities that that specific company
are looking for
so make sure that you don't just go and
end up being stagnant somewhere go and
make your mark if you're interning in
the mail room at an agency
then talk to people about why you want
to be an agent or why you want to be
there or the things that you can bring
to the agency or say hey can
i know so and so is busy can i maybe do
coverage can i read coverage and you're
doing it as an intern you're doing it
for free and maybe you deliver coverage
that's really good they're going to want
you to start doing coverage and they're
going to pay you or say you know if so
and so is sick can i step in and sit on
the desk as an intern if you do well at
the desk as an assistant they're
probably going to promote you to an
assistant so
i don't think interning is a bad idea
just get your foot in the door if you
have the qualities and the assets that
these companies need they'll end up
taking you
so any way that you can show off that
you know i think is is important and if
interning is that route then take it
you